okay so let's take a break from
Spider-Man for a minute since we've been
covering a lot of that recently and
let's talk about Dottie Kate's Hulk
which by the way this was drawn by Ryan
ottley not gonna lie it's a little weird
to see Donnie Cates writing a comic and
Ryan Stegman not drawing it those are
the ones who did Venom for those of you
guys who don't know uh it was really
really good so those guys are kind of
like a one-two punch to a degree but uh
but this is the beginning of the new
Incredible Hulk story arc under Donnie
Kate so we are finished with Al Ewing's
Immortal Hulk that's kind of a
self-contained story uh this one kind of
builds off of it but we may do a full
story let me know if you guys are
interested in seeing like an immortal
Hulk full story video I don't think
we've done that yet but something else
to also keep in mind is that this is a
monthly Series so this will be coming
out once every month uh so we won't be
covering it like every week or every day
like we'll cover them as they come out
but what this does here is this
basically picks up with the incredible
Hulk like punching against a wall which
is kind of a weird thing right it's
literally just like a giant door kind of
out in the middle of nowhere and we get
this sword of you know Exposition here
right it says things like you know I
have long held a theory about the Hulk
that I've never shared it before because
quite frankly it terrifies me to the
very core that we've always thought of
the Hulk as the manifestation of Dr
Banner's trauma that he experienced as a
child or perhaps his ID his shadow his
Fury and then the question becomes but
what if the Hulk is none of those things
what if it exists to protect us from
Banner himself and that's a cool thing
right so one of the great things about
Donnie Cates those of you guys who don't
know he's very very very very good at
looking at the status quo for an
existing character and then flipping it
on its head and so what you end up doing
is actually switching to this discussion
between Bruce Banner and Betty Ross and
it's kind of a crazy thing because of
course he tells you you know Betty
you're not supposed to be here and she
really approaches him with this
conversation about what he's doing with
the Hulk that he can't simply keep the
Incredible Hulk locked into that
particular location now this is kind of
interesting because what Donnie case is
doing is kind of toying with us a little
bit in relation to like Jason Aaron's
Incredible Hulk run and then like the
traditional incredible hook Mythos and
the reason why I say that is because as
you guys know with the traditional
Incredible Hulk Mythos the Hulk is a
manifestation of banner so they're
basically two different people sharing
the same body right like Bruce Banner
physically transforms into the
Incredible Hulk what Jason Aaron did
during his run on Hulk is he actually
wrote a story whereby the two of them
were split so you had Bruce Banner in a
separate body from The Incredible Hulk
and that's happened over the years right
during the onslaught Saga for example
the psychic consciousness of Bruce
Banner was removed from the Incredible
Hulk in order to provide a kind of just
pure Savage Hulk that was really the
most powerful version of his character
we'd seen up to that point that was the
only real memes to basically defeat or
at least find a way to defeat Onslaught
that kind of a thing and so Donnie Cates
isn't really creating new ground here
he's kind of retreading existing ground
but doing it in his own way which is a
cool thing and so ultimately Banner's
response to Betty is one of hostility at
least as it pertains to the Hulk that
Betty kind of used the Incredible Hulk
is very much like a child and he really
is right the Incredible Hulk is very
childlike in terms of how he operates
unless you're talking about world
breaker Hulk or something like that but
Savage Hulk is very very childlike in
that way and so what Betty says is that
she's concerned about this because
hurting the Incredible Hulk is hurting
banner and it's one of those things
where she's like you can't blame
yourself for what happened in El Paso
now for those of you guys who are
approaching this from the perspective of
okay did I miss something from Immortal
Hulk no you didn't there was a recent
interview that Donnie Cates did where he
answered that question because it was
the one thing that people wanted to know
was like okay did we miss something from
Immortal Hulk that happened in El Paso
or something like that and during his
interview with comicbook.com he said no
like it's a thing that has not been
revealed yet it's just something that
took place between the end of immortal
Hulk and the beginning of this run but
whatever it was that took place out
there Banner just kind of freaks out and
says he doesn't really blame himself he
blames The Incredible Hulk and so
ultimately his feelings about how the
world perceives him really come out and
manifest here and this is something that
you don't readily see from Banner where
Betty says that like you're scaring me
right you can't act like this you don't
sound like yourself then the response
also Banner is and how would you know
what I sound like right how would
anybody know the only time I'm ever
useful to any of you all is when I'm not
here when you need the Incredible Hulk
and he says I never wanted any of this
right I never wanted to be a superhero
or a defender or an Avenger or a monster
he's like I never wanted to do any of
this stuff all I wanted to do was push
boundaries all I wanted to be was a man
of science and so he says at the end of
the day it didn't work like none of that
happened and so because of that he says
like this this whole thing right like
this Incredible Hulk it grew inside of
me like some kind of a tumor some kind
of an illness you know and and I Was a
Fool to believe that it would ever stop
growing in the first place to believe
that I could somehow control the Hulk or
contain the Hulk that after the events
of of dealing with the one below all and
the one above all that I somehow had a
stronger grasp on all this I Was a Fool
to believe any of that but more so than
that the biggest concern that Bruce
Banner has is that at some point in time
the Incredible Hulk is going to manifest
he's going to take over and his fear is
not that the Incredible Hulk is is going
to kill his friends or anything like
that it's that the Incredible Hulk will
stay that way that Banner will never
come back out again right to the
Incredible Hulk will basically find a
way to stay in control and you'll never
ever see Banner he'll lose himself and
that's one of the funny things where
again Donnie Cates is building on
History here specifically with Peter
David's The Incredible Hulk the end for
those of you guys who never read that
story it was a phenomenal story where
basically the Incredible Hulk was the
last living thing on Earth right we're
not really thin he was the last living
uh superhero last living person on Earth
and that all that was left after this
just catastrophic nuclear war was
basically just him and like giant bugs
that would eat him on a daily basis and
he would heal himself and all that kind
of stuff but there's one point near the
end of the story or really at the end of
the story where he lashes out his Banner
who's basically grown old and he screams
at Banner that like I want you to go
away right Holst just wants to be alone
and then the banner Persona basically
dies of old age however that works and
so because of that the Incredible Hulk
is eternally left alone on earth like
he'll just be on Earth forever and
that'll be it until such a time that
either Earth is colonized by some alien
race or Life Begins Anew and begins to
evolve that the Incredible Hulk will
seemingly just live on forever as the
only occupant of the planet Earth itself
unless he finds a way to leave the
important thing is this is one of those
stories that Donnie Cates is referencing
here and so it's kind of an interesting
thing because in the end we kind of find
out who would agree what's really going
on here when Banner tells Betty Ross Get
Out of My Head Right like get out of my
head and leave me alone this is how it
might as well end and so what he does
here is he sits on what's basically like
a captain's chair and then he says like
these waves Do Not Crash on me they
break on me because I I am strong and
then from there you basically switch
over to the Avengers I know it's weird
but it makes perfect sense here in a
second and I really love what Donnie
Cates is doing here right so the first
thing you do is you pick up a Spider-Man
who's basically talking to the rest of
the fully assembled Avengers and the
Fantastic Four and the question is asked
is like okay is anybody else super
confused about what's going on here
and the response of Doctor Strange is
what Bruce Banner has managed to achieve
here goes beyond anything anybody has
done right that in effect the Incredible
Hulk becomes the single most powerful
being on the face of the planet and
here's the reason why it's one of those
things where you can kind of extrapolate
it but the idea is that when Doctor
Strange starts talking about this he
says that what he's built that not even
Doctor Strange could have achieved it
right the doctor strange says he scoured
the Earth searching and questioning
every Mystic and omega-level telepath
that he could possibly find to see if
they could do such a thing and none of
them could Bruce Banner managed to
achieve something that the most powerful
beings on the face of the planet were
unable to do himself but then estranged
says there's no way the banner could
have done it himself that it just
doesn't make any sense the magic
required is just beyond anything and so
at the end of the day of course Captain
America kind of reels him back in and
says tell us what's going on and so what
we end up learning here is that Bruce
Banner had basically fractured his mind
into three distinct parts and by
unifying these Parts but controlling
them individually he's basically made
what's being referred to as a Starship
right now the term Starship is a loose
term here this is not something like the
end of like Moonwalker right where like
Michael Jackson turned into a ship and
flew away that's not what we're talking
about here
it's it's the phrase or the term
Starship in relation to basically how
the Incredible Hulk exists right now now
the other thing about this is that the
Incredible Hulk is making its way
towards one to Gore Mountain looking for
a particular thing and it's kind of
crazy because along the way he's
basically fighting Iron Man and four
Hulkbuster armors which is nuts and he's
overpowering them all but what Doctor
Strange tells us is that these three
distinct parts are eloquently designed
and really work as a singular cohesive
unit what Banner had done first and
foremost is he had stolen technology
from Advanced idea mechanics and then
basically use that technology to enhance
the skin for lack of a better word of
the Incredible Hulk basically he's made
the Incredible Hulk more durable than he
was before as if he needed it the
Incredible Hulk was already one of the
most durable beings out there like being
able to successfully physically injure
the Hulk is no small thing I mean you
could make his nose bleed if you were
strong enough right like the thing has
done that but if you're talking about
like literally cutting the Hulk removing
a limb or something like that you need
something like adamantium possibly
vibranium and most likely something like
carbonadium or the muramasa blade in
order to pull that off you would need a
highly specialized weapon to achieve
that what Banner's done here is
basically push that durability beyond
what we've previously seen with his
character and we'll actually see how far
deep that goes because it gets nuts the
second thing that Banner's done is he's
built this giant mind Palace like
nothing Doctor Strange has ever seen
before so much so that there's not a
singular telepath on Earth that can get
through it no one can break through it
Emma Frost Professor Xavier of the X-Men
no one can break through this psychic
barrier that Bruce Banner has erected in
the mind of the incred edible Hulk and
then following that of course you have
this kind of you know conversation not
really a conversation so much just
taunting back and forth between banner
and Iron Man right where it's kind of
like you know yeah yeah you can't beat
me so on and so forth but like he
crushes them all in terms of the
durability of Iron Man this is where
things get cool so one of the things
that he does here is he basically fires
off what are basically these rockets
that have adamantium nanoparticles
shrapnel inside of them in effect what
happens these are like little just tiny
shards of adamantium they burrow
themselves into the body of whatever
their target happens to be and then due
to their Nano programming they basically
forged the adamantium at an atomic level
in effect adamantium grows from the
inside out and so for the Incredible
Hulk this is designed to grow in the
form of a cage to basically lock him
down in place and so that's when you get
into the third thing or the third aspect
of what Bruce Banner's done here that
the Incredible Hulk itself is powered by
rage right as you guys know the angrier
The Incredible Hulk gets the stronger he
gets what if you were able to find a way
to weaponize that and so that's what
Banner's done that Banner sitting in
this kind of captain's chair is
basically controlling the body of the
Incredible Hulk but what of the
Incredible Hulk's Consciousness Banner
has actually taken that and locked it
away and that's what you saw in that
opening scene when he was punching on
that door that Banner has imprisoned the
psyche of the Incredible Hulk and then
basically subjects him to constant
bombardment by enemy forces whenever he
needs him to become angry and because
the Incredible Hulk is childlike the
Incredible Hulk is going to attack
whatever it is that's attacking him and
he's gonna become angrier the longer the
conflict goes on because these are
basically infinite armies that would be
attacking him he would just become
angrier and angrier and angrier
basically Bruce Banners found a way to
weaponize the Incredible Hulk's rage
that rage is the engine that Bruce
Banner is using so what's basically
going on here to kind of give you guys a
better perception is that Bruce Banner
used technology to modify the body of
the Incredible Hulk to make him more
more durable he in turn took over the
mind of the Incredible Hulk and he uses
the Incredible Hulk's rage to decide how
angrier and how powerful the Incredible
Hulk is going to get so basically just
imagine that at any point in time in any
fight that uh that Bruce Banner could
just amp The Incredible Hulk up to like
World breaker levels on a whim that's
what we're talking about here weaponized
World breaker horror it's nuts and so in
this conflict because of the fact that
the adamantium is basically holding him
in place and not even the Incredible
Hulk is strong enough to physically
break through adamantium he actually
rips his arm out of it and when he does
it literally tears his arm off like
which is kind of crazy so he's basically
pummeling Tony Stark with one arm
against all these Hulkbuster suits right
like literally all these hulkbusters
suits that he has are getting totally
obliterated with his one arm and then he
takes one of the arms of the Hulkbuster
suits and attaches it to his snapped arm
right so his arm that was ripped off and
then just goes forward from there and so
what you end up finding is that the
immortal Hulk traveling here of course
once this arm is basically healed which
really only took a couple of minutes
right if that maybe like 30 seconds to
fully heal which gives you a real
indication of just how powerful and
durable he is that what he was looking
for was actually something that Tony
Stark built project Arc so the idea
behind this is that in the aftermath of
the events of King and black when null
had attacked the world that null
overcame the world super fast right
showing up with celestials different
things like that and Tony Stark who is
Ever the futurist began developing a
kind of suit of armor that would serve
one part as protection and then one part
as basically a Gateway as a wormhole and
that's why you see in its chest is what
looks like a giant portal energy source
where the Arc Reactor would normally be
and what would happen here is that in a
time of a massive emergency he could
actually Evacuate the world's population
through this thing now the other thing
about it and those of you guys who are
X-Men fans is probably not lost on you
this looks like master mold and I have
to believe there's probably a reason for
that but what this looks like because of
the fact that Tony Stark piloted a
Celestial is that it looks like it's a
Celestial killer armor is what it looks
like right like Iron Man's Celestial
killer armor which is kind of nuts but
at the end of the day the response of
Hulk is I'm gonna need to borrow this so
you know despite Tony Stark begging for
him not to that the math is not complete
he has no idea where he'll go if he
passes through that portal if you'll
basically take control of the suit of
armor itself or if you'll end up in some
hellish Dimension or the realm of
Mephisto or the Negative Zone there's no
way to know what will happen the
responsive Banner is I don't care it
doesn't matter to me what I want to
achieve is more important so he
literally travels through the portal to
a future destination and we have no idea
what awaits him there
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and I forgot
that Hulk number two was coming out two
weeks after Hulk number one now after
this it's only coming out every month so
we'll have to wait like a month before
we cover the next issue I know it sucks
one of the things a lot of you guys have
voice to concern about is that sometimes
it's hard to keep track of stories so
what I'm gonna do is I'm actually just
going to kind of create playlists for
the individual stories that we're doing
so they're super easy to follow we'll
probably end up with a million playlists
but there's no such thing as too many
playlists on YouTube so for those of you
guys who are following Devil's Reign
you'll actually find a link to the
playlist in that video which right now
only has one video and then for this one
uh you'll find a link to the playlist uh
both for this individual story arc and
this video will also be added into the
main playlist for the Incredible Hulk so
that'll make it easier to follow along
having said that so in the first video
what we kind of talked about and what we
ran over here was really the change that
was going on with the Incredible Hulk
this idea that what Banner had done in
the aftermath of like everything that Al
Ewing had done which was just a
ridiculously Amazing Story which we
still need to release a full story for
for Immortal Hulk um that what's
happened here is Banner has basically
weaponized The Incredible Hulk insofar
that he basically turned him into a ship
because the Incredible Hulk is so
incredibly durable and so powerful he
can survive in almost any environment
and one of the things that was
established in Jason Aaron's run is that
the Incredible Hulk's physiology can
actually adapt to an environment so he
wasn't able to breathe underwater until
he was
and so what this means is that with
Banner basically controlling the mind of
the Incredible Hulk and the Incredible
Hulk's rage being used as quote unquote
the engine that drives the ship that
he's basically able to do almost
anything he wants to and so far as
executing plants we don't really know
what this plan is what we do know is
that Banner basically sees control of
basically Celestial Tech and then in
turn traveled into the Multiverse now
the funny thing about this is that as
soon as he leaves his Universe he comes
across a group that's referred to as the
alternate universe timeline Hazard
operations response and intervention
team with some other word that starts
with a y it's Authority this looks like
Authority from DC Comics those of you
guys who don't know who that is the
authority is actually a group that
operates essentially in the Multiverse
but they they well they've served
different purposes but they're a wild
Storm Team uh we haven't really talked
about them and maybe we should we
haven't really done much of the way of
Wild Storm but this is hilarious because
at the end of the day he just plows
through
I mean none of these guys really have a
chance but it is kind of a funny thing
to see I mean tell me this ship in the
background does not look like the ship
of the authority from wildstorm they're
basically a Pastiche right I mean if
they're not exactly those characters
they're basically a past Niche but when
it comes to the Multiverse this is one
of the things I want to talk about we I
like to reiterate this every so often
for people who were either new or who
have been here for a while and need a
bit of a refresher there are a lot of
teams that Patrol the Multiverse for
different reasons like the Exiles travel
from one Universe to the other just
basically solving problems and we should
cover the original like not really the
original but like the Exiles run uh that
basically went into what was basically
House of M and all that kind of stuff
did like the world tour storyline and
all that we should probably cover that
because the Exiles are like the most
underappreciated but more most amazing
team in Marvel Comics like literally
it's just a team that travels to
alternate realities all their like every
one of their stories was awesome there
was never a boring story in the Exiles
but nonetheless these guys are
obliterated pretty quickly the other
thing behind this is that Banner is
basically asleep at the wheel and it
kind it makes sense right I mean it's a
pretty exhausting situation to be in
controlling uh giant green rage monster
and then you know sending him into space
A lot's happened over the course of the
day A lot's happened over the course of
the day and so once Banner starts to
wake up what you actually end up finding
out here is they're being targeted and
the reason why is because there's
somebody out there or something out
there that's trying to get their hands
on the Hulk for reasons we don't
necessarily know we simply know that
they are but again this is the nature of
using the Incredible Hulk's rage as an
engine system that where this really
beginning called a kind of a physical
tractor beam is trying to pull the The
Incredible Hulk in that Banner amps's
rage up right as a means to just kind of
keep the or at least push the Incredible
Hulk to higher levels thinking of this
is something akin to like NOS in a car
except you could regulate how much Nas
you basically allow in that car and you
basically have it just increasing in
power forever right is is kind of the
big difference here but again like
monsters are basically introduced get
set upon the Incredible Hulk one of
which is Finn Fang Foom uh spoilers have
you guys played the Guardians of the
Galaxy game yet dude that game is
amazing I just finished it like a couple
days ago Dude that game is amazing Finn
Fang Foom looked awesome in that game
when they when they're like we need to
go find Finn Fang Foom I was like yes
I really can't wait to see this but the
thing behind this is that again these
are just monsters and the Incredible
Hulk in what's essentially his is almost
like infantile form is Savage form just
sees them as a credible threat and
attacks them that's one of the benefits
that Banner's kind of waiting for when
it comes to the Incredible Hulk if the
Incredible Hulk has not figured out this
is an illusion now this is one of the
big differences between what Donnie
Cates is doing and what Al Ewing is
doing that in a lot of ways Al Ewing
depicted the intelligence of the
immortal Hulk or at least his ability to
understand his surroundings as being on
par with Ben right I mean the immortal
Hulk was not as intelligent as Banner
right it wasn't one of those things
where he's like practicing science and
things like that certainly not on the
same level the banner was but he was
certainly a lot more cognizant of what
was going on around him right he was
able to understand what was taking place
and a more nuanced way than what Savage
Hulk is able to do now whether or not
this means the immortal Hulk slash devil
Hulk Persona is gone forever or is
temporarily just kind of retreated is
something that only time will tell right
we'll just kind of have to wait and and
watch is Donnie Cates and progressed to
find out how this happens but regardless
what the immortal Hulk's anger being
amped up more and more at the End of the
Day banners told that the origin of this
entity is unknown but according to their
sensors they're being scanned and when
it turns out they're being scanned for
gamma radiation the initial response to
Banner is it's the Avengers right like
they're trying to find him or they have
found him and they're basically trying
to bring this guy back right they're
trying to reel him back into the
universe because the reality is he's not
supposed to be out there right like he
he overpowered The Avengers in order to
get to this and so following that you
basically have him of course taking out
Fin Fang Foom and you know the The
Incredible Hulk destroys these forces or
whatever and so Banner needs more rage
and so as a really great throwback he
basically amps them up and has a giant
version of Wolverine appear here now on
the surface you would think that if what
Banner wanted to do was to maximize The
Rage of the Hulk that he would somehow
find a way to unlock the world breaker
Hulk rage level right to make him you
know as angry as he as he's ever been
but there's a couple reasons for why we
can surmise this is not really happening
the first is that to go from just Hulk
who's kind of chill and relaxed or at
least is you know kind of minimally
angry we can call him that until like
World breaker Hulk could possibly just
destroy his form right like I mean
destroy the the engine so to speak right
the other part of this is that given the
fact that the the world breaker Hulk
form is essentially a more cognizant and
intelligent version of savage Hulk that
what this would mean is that it would
figure out us all an illusion right like
World breaker Hulk would figure out
what's going on and then basically just
stop right and just just cease to fight
and just kind of maybe revert back to a
base form and call it a day there's a
few different reasons for why we can
discern that's not necessarily happening
the other cool thing here is that this
being a throwback is to the old
Wolverine first appearance when he
fought the Incredible Hulk this is how
he looked right this is this is how
Wolverine looked back in the day not
only that as most of you guys know uh
The Incredible Hulk and Wolverine have
had some ridiculously good fights
especially with that animated movie
right Hulk versus and it's like
Wolverine and Thor you guys remember
that movie that movie was awesome I'm
gonna watch that movie as soon as I
finish with this video well it was a it
was a great movie right it was it was a
great thing I absolutely loved it uh but
there's been some great battles here
right and there's a lot of I wouldn't
say animosity but Wolverine kind of
represents this being that's very
difficult for the Incredible Hulk to
take out and so the Incredible Hulk's
rage just kind of keeps going and going
and going but as the fight breaks on or
continues on between Wolverine and uh
and and the Incredible Hulk the Hulk's
not getting as angry as he needs to be
the engines themselves are also critical
so it's almost as though the engines
kind of match what the Hulk is going
through now you do get some cool moments
right where like giant Wolverine goes
you know goes to stab The Immortal Hulk
and his claws gets stuck in the ground
and Hulk rips out one of Wolverine's
claws which is awesome it's just
ridiculously cool to see but the the
this kind of disembodied Betty Ross
right who almost seems to be a voice in
Banner's head to a degree seemingly his
conscience kind of chimes in and is like
you're pushing the Incredible Hulk too
far like if you keep on doing this
either he's gonna break he's gonna shut
down and he's basically like that that
Persona is gonna be destroyed possibly
replaced with another or simply just
losing your ability ability to power
this engine entirely or everything is
going to go belly up the crazy thing
about this is that if this version of
the Incredible Hulk is seemingly
defeated slash destroyed that what would
happen is Banner would revert back into
his human form right like remember all
this is essentially taking place in the
mindscape right like this ship that
banners sitting in is the brain of the
Incredible Hulk and the Incredible Hulk
himself is just his Persona fighting all
these enemies that banners making him
see that appear to be real but actually
aren't right that's one thing to keep in
mind this is not happening on some
Planet somewhere right that's not really
what's going on here but that if this
version of the Incredible Hulk is
defeated or destroyed that the
Incredible Hulk will revert back into
his human form and banner cannot
withstand the rigors of the Multiverse
in his current form right Jake like as a
human being he cannot withstand that he
would basically be destroyed and so
that's why there's a bit of desperation
here that's why there's a bit of a
desire to to kind of push the Incredible
Hulk more and more and find some way to
get past this ultimately though the
Incredible Hulk succumbs to this this
kind of tractor system that's pulling
him in and there's no conceivable way
for them to find a way out and so
essentially once they're pulled back in
here or into this particular location
they crash land in what basically looks
like a cave with a kind of stasis field
thus keeping the Incredible Hulk in
place now we're not really given the
details of this stasis field and in
reality we don't really need them but I
would surmise that given how it's
Technology based it's likely one of
those things where it basically
reinforces the strike of the Incredible
Hulk so for every punch he Doles out
that level of strength is Amplified two
times over by the shield so basically
The Shield is always more durable than
the Incredible Hulk is right like the
Incredible Hulk strength works against
him and being able to try to break out
of this thing the crazy thing is that
there's just this kind of guy out there
right like this this person out there
that you can't really make out this says
that like after all these years they
finally caught him right they finally
caught this person and where Banner
doesn't know what's going on right like
who in the hell are you like what what
in the heck is happening here the the
person kind of chimes in and says wow
you're wildly different from all the
rest of them right you can speak you can
reason and you're in control like this
is kind of weird like don't be afraid I
mean you harm my name is Dr Bruce Banner
this looks like Bruce Banner from an
alternate reality now try as I might
this is not an existing version of Bruce
Banner that I'm familiar with and I've
searched high and low this is not a
version of banner that we've seen before
so it's not like the Incredible Hulks
landed in like the House of M universe
and this is Banner in that Universe this
is a seemingly a reality that we've
never seen before which makes me wildly
excited to see what Donnie Cates is
gonna do here
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the Hulk right with uh
with Hulk part three and and I don't
know why I keep getting the wires
crossed with like Donnie Cates and Al
Ewing like in the Venom video we were
like it's Donnie case's Venom but it's
actually Al Ewing's Venom it's probably
because the two of them directly switch
stories which always throws me off
Donnie Cates was writing Venom valuing
his writing Hulk then they switched and
Dottie case is riding Hulk and alien's
writing Venom and it just it takes me
for a loop sometimes so I may make that
mistake a couple more times hopefully
not I'll try to make sure I don't but
the whole idea behind the Incredible
Hulk is Donnie Cates is writing it right
now uh is that basically Bruce Banner is
piloting The Incredible Hulk now if you
want to get caught up make sure you guys
check out the playlist down in the
description which will not only have
this Incredible Hulk story all the way
at the bottom but we'll also have a
whole bunch of other Incredible Hulk
stuff to go along with it including the
immortal Hulk uh but the whole thing
behind this is that Banner is basically
in an alternate reality and the crazy
thing is that this alternate reality
he's in is one that's actually occupied
by in another version of Bruce Banner
now before we get into that there is
something really important here and this
is one of those instances where Dottie
Cates teases a thing and then kind of
gives us this slow introduction it's
usually what he always does you can set
your watch to it right so he'll give us
like the first two issues which will set
the stage and then we'll get issue
number three which is something's coming
and then we'll get Issue Number Four
which may or may not focus on that and
then with five and six we'll basically
come to the fruition of what's going on
with the thing he discussed assuming
he's going to keep it confined to those
six issues and not really like build it
up as something that'll show up in like
you know 12 or 24 issues later on down
the line but the thing about this and
really the big question that we'd all
had is that at the end of Al Ewing's run
on the immortal Hulk that banner and
Hulk had basically kind of found a way
to work in unison right there was
Harmony there as there usually always is
when it comes to the ending of a Hulk
story what we didn't know is what had
happened between the time of the ending
of immortal Hulk and the events in El
Paso when things had basically popped
off and the Incredible Hulk had somehow
lost his mind instead tearing everything
up that what had basically happened is
things that kind of gone back to the
status quo that basically whenever the
Incredible Hulk essentially came on that
where he and banner would kind of work
in unison and both would basically know
what the other one was doing that Banner
was basically shut out and so things
started going nuts and he didn't fully
understand what was happening the other
part of this is that when the when the
questions asked what happened like like
you know his belief being that like the
Incredible Hulk could basically just
taken over shut Banner's mind out and
then went on a war path in El Paso
killed a whole bunch of people and then
basically you know kind of reverted back
into Banner that instead there's
something else going on here that
seemingly there's another kind of Hulk
presence that's there almost demonic in
nature and then just basically refers to
Banner as being weak and then kills
Banner right off the bat now of course
this is him seemingly having like a
dream experience it's not actually him
experiencing that so we don't know
exactly how this unfolded if it was a
vision that took place in El Paso if
it's something that he's just imagining
right some sort of way for him to kind
of cope with the the things is it like
the Incredible Hulk actually did in El
Paso we don't necessarily know all we
know is that he basically wakes up in
this alternate reality and is met with
this version of Bruce Banner now the
crazy thing about this is that this
alternate reality version of banner as
he says he describes him as being
magnificent and says I have never met an
Abomination with such agency before and
so seemingly in this alternate reality
there appears to be more than one Hulk
and those various versions that are out
there don't really have the same kind of
intelligence that Bruce Banner does now
the funny thing about this is that this
is kind of the exception to the rule
whether it's because of the fact that
Bruce Banner is basically controlling
The Incredible Hulk so like piloting The
Hulk and using the Hulk's anger as a
means to essentially control his body to
increase his strength or decrease his
strength as needed or previous
iterations where you had like Professor
Hulk or even like World breaker Hulk or
something like that that regardless of
the situation seemingly this alternate
reality version of banner has never
encountered that and so when the the
main Marvel Universe Banner introduced
himself as I am basically Bruce Ben and
I'm controlling The Incredible Hulk I'm
piloting him basically like my mind is
controlling the body then this alternate
reality version of banner is like okay
that's interesting I'm curious about
this and so of course with the
Incredible Hulk Persona it really is his
mind kind of facing off against all
these different threats that Banner
shuts the threats down which of course
lead to the Incredible Hulk Persona
basically calming down right remember
that's how this whole thing works the
Incredible Hulk is basically the engine
that you have the physical Incredible
Hulk's body but you have the mind of
Bruce Banner that's controlling The
Incredible Hulk's body and that what you
have is the Incredible Hulk mind
basically the Savage Hulk's mind being
forced to fight enemy after enemy after
enemy increasing his Rage which allows
the Incredible Hulk to stay strong so
Banner can basically control the Hulk's
strength right remember that's kind of
the thing that's going on here it's
interesting and it's kind of meta
textual but in the midst of all this
kind of happening The Incredible Hulk
Persona meets with what looks like this
kind of dark demonic devil Hulk version
the crazy thing is that he seems to have
seen him before it's one of those things
where he's like you right like who who
are you and then when this version takes
off the whole kind of chases after him
right and it's like please come back so
it's an interesting concept because it
looks as though the Incredible Hulk
wants this kind of devil version of
himself or this being or whatever it is
this happens to be again we don't fully
know what's going on here the important
thing that to really discuss here is
basically main Marvel Universe Banner
talking to alternate banner and what we
get is this bit of an origin story in
that this alternate reality Universe
version of Bruce Banner says that unlike
the main Marvel Universe where the gamma
bomb had gone off but Banner had
basically pushed Rick Jones out of the
way was exposed to the radiation and
then became the Incredible Hulk leading
to General Thunderbolt Ross and all
those guys riding the whole thing off as
a failure and basically saying aftermath
of this is basically just too dangerous
that in this alternate reality it worked
right the gamma bomb went off without a
hitch Banner was not caught in the blast
he never became the Incredible Hulk or
anything along those lines but in his
naivety he believed that this would only
lead to a kind of second atomic age
right that in the aftermath of humanity
discovering atomic energy that yeah I
mean it gave us the Cold War and the
fear that the United States and the
Soviet Union were going to wipe
themselves off the map but it also gave
us microwaves and all kinds of
technology and so the thought of banner
is that sure this could potentially be
used for destructive capabilities but if
for no other reason than
self-preservation Humanity would not
necessarily be quick on the trigger in
terms of just detonating all these gamma
bombs across the world in some major
conflict instead they would use gamma
technology as basically a source of
energy to kind of enter into a new age
of human evolution instead the worst
fears of banner come true that there
seemed to have been some kind of just
massive Global Calamity and what they
ended up doing with the powers that be
as he describes them taking their
weapons and then basically detonating
them across the world everywhere except
for the United States is hit and so what
he says that this whole thing had
basically turned the United States into
the greatest Empire in the world
seemingly it was the US that struck
first for whatever reason which is not
really explained here what seems to have
happened is that the United States using
gamma bombs targeted the rest of the
world and then detonated all those gamma
bombs in populated areas across the
world leaving only itself as seemingly
the last functioning Empire in the world
of the last functioning country in the
world and so Banner has basically been
trying to continually atone for his sins
and when the questions asked what are
you doing to to atone for your sins how
does all this work he basically says
that the ensuing radiation from these
gamma bomb attacks basically affected
everybody across the world those
individuals who weren't killed in the
explosions were transformed into hulks
but instead of them simply just being
like hulks as you expect them right just
like running around and like an
Incredible Hulk type person instead
they're all irradiated so some of them
look like look like crabs some of them
are just kind of like welded in place
and it's just like Hulk heads or
whatever the case is and sometimes like
you do see a kind of version of the Hulk
that basically escapes here's the irony
of all this this is almost exactly how
the events played out in Greg Pack's
Planet Hulk event as part of Secret Wars
right the big difference here is that in
that story everybody in the world were
changed into like tried and true
Incredible Hulks right Incredible Hulks
or she-hulks and like that was basically
it they weren't really mutated or
anything like that it's just everybody
in the world became a Hulk here it's
really a an interesting blend between
the events of Greg Pax Planet Hulk from
Secret Wars which I think was part of
like War zones or something like that
and then uh the events of Incredible
Hulk The End by Peter David right where
basically the world was destroyed in in
nuclear war all the heroes and all the
villains had basically died out in the
Incredible Hulk and banner were like the
last two people on Earth until the Bruce
Banner Persona had a heart attack and
died and then it was just the Incredible
Hulk and and I don't really know how a
Persona has a heart attack and dies but
regardless it's a very interesting blend
between these two things the other part
of this is that because these hulks kind
of appear out in the world every once in
a while and because this alternate
reality version of banner referred to
them as Abominations the question that
the main Marvel Universe Banner is where
are they right when you find these hoax
and you capture them where do they go
what do you do with them and he's like I
found them in the same place that I
found you right out in the void that
basically what this alternate reality
version of banner has been doing is
every time he finds a Hulk he basically
throws them out into the void of the
Multiverse right just sort of throws
them out there into existence he doesn't
know what happens to them he doesn't
really know where they go and it's not
really his concern and he does this
because he's instructed to and when the
questions asked by Banner who instructs
you to do this who tells you to just
throw these Incredible Hulks away right
to just throw them out right to maybe
study them for a little while and then
throw them into the void who tells you
this who is the person that's in charge
here and the response to this alternate
reality version of banner is my father
is it's his father-in-law president
Thunderbolt Ross
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Donnie Kate's run on the
Incredible Hulk and in the last video we
basically ended things seemingly with
this idea that Bruce Banner essentially
seemed to work for like General
Thunderbolt Ross or at the very least
was subservient to General Thunderbolt
Ross who of course had become president
of the United States now the other part
of this is this reality is given a
numerical designation which usually
happens faster than this but this is
referred to as Earth 122. so maybe
that's something that'll become
important later on down the line I'm not
entirely sure usually whenever Marvel
actually assigns a numerical designation
to an alternate reality it usually means
that alternate reality will appear in
the future so again that's why I say you
may or may not want to keep it in the
back of your head the thing about this
is that as we know uh basically
Thunderbolt Ross ends up discovering or
finding out that there is a kind of
enormous amount of gamma energy that it
basically spiked from a specific
mountain range and what this does is it
seems to indicate that Bruce Banner is
actually in hiding from General
thunderbol that he's not actually
working for Thunderbolt Ross per se and
that what ends up happening here is
Thunderbolt Ross of course is like send
everything right like get all the drop
ships going and everything like that and
I want to be there when it all happens
now here's the thing to understand this
would never be allowed to happen the
president of the United States would
never be allowed to enter in active war
zone the Secret Service would keep that
from happening right it just like the
president's not allowed to put himself
In Harm's Way like that I mean he
wouldn't even be allowed to get close he
would never be allowed to enter an
active war zone
but at the end of the day as Grant
Morrison once said this is comics and
none of it's real so why does it matter
so here's the other thing about this the
big question that we kind of had to ask
here is what's going on with the rest of
the world now we don't necessarily get
this in depth we do get a couple
questions answered but really we
basically end up finding out that it's
largely Tony Stark who killed the world
not Tony Stark directly but the
technology of Tony Stark that what ended
up happening is that with everything
following the way that it did right the
gamma Revolution as it was called all
these people with like gamma energy
basically popping up all over the place
that what it did is it made Stark
Technologies essentially obsolete now
this is an important thing because
before Tony Stark became Iron Man as
most of you guys know he was a weapons
manufacturer and whether it's because
you've seen the movie or you've read the
comics it was basically The Art of War
right the danger that comes with war
itself and like the loss of innocent
lives and the fact that Tony Stark was
forced to face that fact when he was
kidnapped while really during the
Vietnam war in the comics versus uh
during the Afghan conflict in uh in the
movies that he ended up turning over a
new leaf and basically using his
technology in order to one make the
world better as well as turning himself
into an Avenger the difference here is
that because this whole gamma Revolution
happened before Tony Stark became Iron
Man or at least maybe after he became
Iron Man this Stark Industries had no
real value and so the result of this is
that Tony Stark filed for bankruptcy
right like literally his company's value
just plummeted because he wasn't
offering anything that was better than
the whole gamma Revolution right the
idea of like gamma-powered beings and so
what this meant is that eventually his
company was absorbed now we're not
really told who it was that absorbed his
company whether it was Justin hammer or
anything like that or even just the
federal government itself the important
thing here is that ultimately Tony Stark
ended up just dying of his alcoholism
right he ended up being found dead
outside of a bar from alcohol toxicity
and basically chronic pancreatitis
following that the technology of Tony
Stark was basically used presumably by
the government to kind of bridge the gap
between the gamma radiation of the
Incredible Hulk and the technology of
Stark to create these basically
gamma-powered Stark uh robots right and
then in turn they started wiping out
everything right like literally the
X-Men popped up shortly after that and
they were all just annihilated by the
federal government right just totally
wiped out completely now the thing about
this is that this looks like it takes
place around the time of giant size
X-Men so not only were the X-Men
eradicated by the forces of basically
the government using Stark Tech but they
also nuked the entire entirety of the
Xavier school for gifted youngsters now
we're not really given much outside of
that it's really just kind of banner
reading about all this stuff in this
alternate reality but what we could also
largely surmise here is that when he
starts asking questions like is there
nobody left right what about blade or
Moon Knight or like Captain America or
even like Spider-Man that like the
response of this alternate reality
Banner is like I don't okay blade or
moon like I have no idea what you're
talking about so seemingly there is no
blade there is no Moon Knight which is
really kind of interesting because in
the main Marvel Universe Eric Brooks
became blade pretty early on and he's
been around for quite some time so
seemingly he may still be around and
just nobody knows about him or maybe he
just never really came into existence at
all uh Captain America may still very
well be frozen in ice it's just one of
those things where we're not really
given a whole lot of answers maybe we
will get them at a at a later point in
time but at the moment we don't really
know what's happening the crazy thing
about this though is that in the middle
of all this you basically end up having
like the forces of Thunderbolt raw so
basically the US government that
descends on this mountain range where
you have the main Marvel Universe banner
and this alternate reality banner and so
what it does is it leads to like
alternate Banner basically telling like
you know the the main Marvel Universe
Banner right don't go out there right
like these this is literally an army
that's bred for the purpose of
destroying people like you right like
they they this this is not like you
running out there and dealing with like
bullets and things like that they
specialize in this and so what you end
up getting is that once Banner shows up
out there it's just like this colossal
army with this these giant Mexico you
know what this reminds me of in a lot of
ways it reminds me of like Days of
Future Past right it looks very very
similar to Dave's Future Past this is
one of the reasons why that story was so
Landmark when it came out and why it has
such a strong Legacy because so often
whenever you look at alternate reality
stories where essentially the
superheroes have basically been killed
off in some form or fashion usually by
the actions of the government itself
that it is some kind of days of future
past-esque scenario right the activation
of some version of The Sentinel program
sometimes the Sentinels become
self-aware other times Sentinels never
deviate from their programming they
never become self-aware and they just
operate based on the programming given
to them by the federal government but
whatever it is the funny thing about
this is Banner tells us alternate
reality counterpart no no right I'm from
a whole different playing field like I
am not these gamma mutates that you see
out there right these gamma-ray radiated
beings just watch and learn my friend
I'm on a whole different level from
these guys now once he jumps out there
and and literally Ross is just like fire
right fire everything they have then it
initially takes Banner by surprise right
like he didn't really believe what
alternative Banner was telling him until
he was being hit with all these lasers
that are literally piercing his skin
right which is a very difficult task to
achieve but in a world full of gamma
irradiated hulks it was only a matter of
time before these before technology was
developed that could overcome those
Hulks and by extension overcome this one
but as you guys know and seemingly one
of the things that makes the main Marvel
Universe version of The Incredible Hulk
so unique is that the angrier he gets
the stronger he gets and so as a result
of this literally Banner just like sets
the whole the whole engine system of the
Incredible Hulk to stage four now
remember those guys who are kind of
getting caught up here that basically
it's Banner controlling the mind of the
Incredible Hulk and by setting the
engine to stage four what he's basically
doing is forcing The Incredible Hulk
personality to experience like all these
different Horrors in these stages of
combat which in turn makes the
Incredible Hulk personality angrier and
it makes the Incredible Hulk's body
stronger and more durable which allows
Banner to continue fighting in places
that he normally wouldn't be able to
fight the thing about this is that by
going to stage four it basically
activates a kind of hallucination of the
Marvel Zombies so literally while like
the Hulk personality is just losing its
mind attacking all these Marvel Zombies
it amps him up more and more his healing
Factor kicks in he recovers almost
instantaneously and then like the
strength boost comes and in doing so he
starts laying waste to the forces of of
Thunderbolt Ross right like at that
point it's really Thunderbolt Ross
realizing he never had a chance in the
first place right like it's just
absolutely absolute madness here and
even this alternate reality version of
banner is like my God like what the hell
have I Unleashed right they have never
seen anything like this in this
alternate universe they've never seen
like a tried and true Incredible Hulk
and that's one of the things that Donnie
Cates really seems to be hitting at is
that yes you have different iterations
of the Incredible Hulk from around the
Multiverse but there only ever really
seems to be one version of The
Incredible Hulk that's as unique as this
now the reality is we know that's not
necessarily the case right I mean the
what if story based on like World War
Hulk where basically Hulk ends up
killing all the superheroes and becomes
a hero of Galactus like that was
basically the same Hulk that we were
used to who seemingly had all the same
Powers right so it's not that uncommon
to see but it seems to be a fairly rare
thing and so what you end up getting is
actually General Thunderbolt Ross who
contacts this alternate banner and it's
just like do something right like call
this guy off if you don't call this guy
off then I'm bringing out your star
pupil right this stupid kid that you
love so much and we're gonna send them
down there and so that's the crazy thing
is because where where Bros is like you
you got 10 seconds right Banner like
literally tries to talk him down he's
like no no like please don't do it
please don't do it he was like call your
monster off or the boy Falls right the
boy gets knocked down into this whole
great big huge thing and so it's one of
those things where like this alternate
reality Banner absolutely cares for this
kid right but at the end of the day he
ends up succumbing to Thunderbolt Ross
and then tells Bruce Banner do you have
to stop this madness right you have to
stop fighting against the forces of Ross
and like the whole time Bruce Banner is
like what are you talking about why do I
have to stop fighting and he never
really gets an answer he doesn't shut
off the engine right he doesn't doesn't
calm The Incredible Hulk down that the
Incredible Hulk Persona keeps going
crazy just like it always did and so as
a result of that the countdown ends and
Ross is just like dunzo and kicks the
kid out of this whole thing and so you
have Bruce Banner talking to his
alternate reality Banner counterparts
and it's like tell me what's going on
like what's happening here and this
alternate reality Banner is like okay so
here's the thing right like this kid was
basically my star pupil right like he
was he was just he was a research
student of mine right he was like a son
to me his name was Peter and he was
bitten by a spider that we had basically
irradiated now when that happens right
in that moment the forces of General
Thunderbolt Ross retreat they clear the
battlefield and when Bruce Banner asked
the question okay this is probably
stupid but this irradiated spider that
bit this kid Peter what kind of
radiation are we talking about here and
what it looks like is it was a gamma
irradiated spider because what manifests
here is one of the most badass
depictions of Spider-Man ever right like
literally this kid lands here and he
ends up transforming into what's
basically a Hulk Spider-Man it is
awesome oh my God you look so good this
is why I love Donnie case man the guy
just pulls these crazy ass rabbits out
of his ass right it's just it's nuts the
kind of stuff that he does this guy's
imagination is just bonkers
okay so getting back into Donnie cates's
Hulk run right picking up where we left
off uh and we'll kind of explain what's
going on to a degree as we go through
this as we usually do just because of
the fact that we're doing these like a
month apart we basically pick up in this
alternate universe with this alternate
reality version of Bruce Banner and we
pick up with this alternate reality
version of General Thunderbolt Ross now
there is this really really amazing
monologue that the that Banner does like
the the main Marvel Universe Banner The
Incredible Hulk does as all this is
happening because remember he's
basically uh fighting this alternate
reality version of Spider-Man who was
also exposed to gamma radiation so like
spider Hulk essentially and what he says
here is he says he wanted to be so much
more than this right he wanted to push
the boundaries explore the unknowable
that he wanted to discover and invent to
create instead on this world every world
that has ever known the name Bruce
Banner the story is always the same like
this alternate me the banner of this
world once said I am become death again
and again and again the destroyer of
worlds now I love that quote I don't
know where how many of you guys know
where that from but it's it actually
comes from a from a Hindu scripture but
it was really it really became a staple
of Pop Culture because of Robert
Oppenheimer after the detonation of the
atomic bomb when it was experimented
witnessing the First Nation um in 1945
after the Manhattan Project he said I
remember the line from the Hindu
scripture the bhagavad-gita Vishnu is
trying to persuade the prince that he
should do his duty and to impress him
takes on his multi-armed form and says
now I am become death the destroyer of
worlds I absolutely love that quote I've
always loved that quote right this is
one of my absolute favorite quotes when
it comes to the the history just just in
general right it's just it's an amazing
quote but nonetheless right this
alternate reality version of Bruce is
basically being pummeled by Thunderbolt
Ross now remember they kind of worked
together to a degree right that Ross
seemingly in this universe and virtually
every other has never really liked Bruce
Banner but the the I guess maybe
alliance between the two despite it
being tenuous was predicated on the idea
that in the attempt of this alternate
reality version of banner to solve the
biowaste problem and accidentally
creating all these different versions of
of Hulks essentially some of whom are
grotesquely mutated others are
relatively normal in terms of their
appearance that in order to correct this
mistake they would basically send them
through a wormhole and who knows where
they would go now one of the things
Donnie Cates tells us is that ultimately
we'll find out where they go to
we'll find out where it is that they all
end up at but regardless it's just this
really really cool moment because what
Ross wants here and basically pummeling
this alternate reality version of banner
is he wants to know what this Hulk is
where it came from and how to kill it
and that's the crazy thing is because
this version of Hulk this alternate
reality Hulk represents this huge threat
to this alternate version of Thunderbolt
Ross because it could destabilize
everything he's built now remember in
terms of how the Incredible Hulk
operates right now it's the Incredible
Hulk's strength that is basically
motivated by The Incredible Hulk itself
that what you have here is you have
Banner who controls the mind of the
Incredible Hulk and and that he
basically forces the Incredible Hulk
psyche to face off against all these
different threats and as you guys know
the longer a fight goes on for and the
more difficult it becomes for the
Incredible Hulk to defeat a foe the
angrier The Incredible Hulk becomes and
the angrier the Hulk becomes the
stronger he becomes so quite literally
Bruce Banner has turned the Incredible
Hulk Persona into a source of power that
he can manipulate right he can literally
ramp It Up by stages ramp it down by
stages have him face off against all
kinds of credible threats and so the
result of this is right now they're at
stage four basically the Incredible Hulk
Persona is fighting Marvel Zombies in
his own mind and because the Incredible
Hulk cannot differentiate right it's
basically a child it doesn't know that
what it's seeing is not real it thinks
it is and so it's just pummeling
everything it sees and as the Fight
Continues to go on the Incredible Hulk
Persona gets angrier and angrier and
gets stronger and stronger and so
because of this again Betty Ross has
intermittently kind of appeared in the
mind of banner and just kind of talked
to him occasionally and one of the
things that she says is she asks like
what are you doing right like you know
you're not going to kill that poor thing
and the responsive Banner is I mean like
what are you talking about and the
answer that Betty offers is like he's
just a child right he can't help what he
is and that's when Banner gets a little
irritated and just kind of like you know
what is this right since when do you
care so much about protecting these
supposed children why is this so
important to you and that's when when
Betty's like Bruce I don't exist right
I'm not a I'm a manifestation of your
own mind but she says I know what
happens when you lock a child away and
abuse it when you take its freedoms away
it's agency it bottles all of that up
right all of that Fury all of that rage
when you do that Bruce the child turns
into what made it you know this better
than anyone you were turned into what
you are by your father right like you
hurt people you did bad things to people
right like the Incredible Hulk Persona
is a manifestation of the abuse you
experience at the hands of your father
right rage given a physical form and she
says now you have to ask yourself if you
lock the Hulk away and you keep hurting
it keep making it angrier making it
bottle up all of that rage when when
that child explodes what will he turn
into and the responsive Banner is I
don't know but let's find out and that's
when he ramps it up to stage five in
order to defeat this you know mutated
version of Spider-Man and at this point
now it's fighting Gods it's fighting
certain and like Thor and Beta Ray Bill
and like Loki and all these people which
again makes the Hulk angrier and angrier
now the Hulk is able to overcome this uh
this this mutated spider you know spider
Hulk he's able to overcome him but at
that point or at least uh kind of get
the fight to the point where spider
spider Hulk is on the ropes but what you
do here is you basically switch over to
this alternate reality version of banner
and it says like I try to tell you
everything like I I've told you
everything I know right like there's no
conceivable way that I know of to kill
this version of The Incredible Hulk and
that's when you end up having uh having
Thunderbolt Ross who lays his chips on
the on the table right he tells the
tells the guys to leave and he basically
Reveals His Hand and what he says here
is that in reality uh at the end of the
day when it came to like all these
different versions of the Hulk that this
alternate reality version of banner it
accidentally created that General
Thunderbolt Ross wasn't just getting rid
of them indiscriminately that what he
was doing was actually weaponizing them
that the ones who were weaker the ones
who couldn't serve a useful purpose they
were all discarded they were sent to the
portal to end up wherever it was that
they ended up at but the reality is the
ones who were stronger the ones who
could be used for Warfare right that
they were kept and in fact Reed Richards
in this alternate universe had actually
made it possible for Thunderbolt Ross to
essentially control these versions of
the Hulk and then in turn they've used
them to fight Wars right though one of
the things that Thunderbolt Ross has
said is that he had to use the ordinance
that the equivalent to the GDP of
multiple Nations that have been
conscripted or taken over by the US so
what this means or what this seems to
indicate is that the geopolitical
landscape is not the way that it is in
the main Marvel Universe it's not the
United States of America Canada Mexico
Russia any of the number of countries
that are in Europe right China that
instead things seem to have changed
drastically and we don't necessarily
know what what continents or what
nations the United States has taken over
but the United States has taken over a
lot of them right they they seem to
control a huge part of the world and the
Incredible Hulks that were basically
being taken by uh by Thunderbolt Ross
that had accidentally been created by
Banner they were instrumental in making
that happen and so while it's not
necessarily the fault of banner
Thunderbolt Ross plays it off by saying
in a way it is like you sure like all
these Incredible Hulks they were an
accident created by you it wasn't your
intention you were just trying to solve
the biowaste problem but you literally
gave us weapons and while I never told
you before I used them to win Wars right
I just kind of kept it hidden from you
and so that's the crazy thing is because
what happens is that in the middle of
all this you have the fight going on
between Hulk and and you know spider
Hulk and the actual real world where
that's where that fight is taking place
but the reality is all these bombs are
dropped by Thunderball Ross right and
when that happens it's not enough to
kill spider Hulk or anything but it's
certainly enough to basically destroy
the visor of uh of banner and when that
happens like Banner is like literally
the whole thing goes nuts right like
Banner's just kind of blown out of his
seat and all that kind of stuff and
while it is a little weird because
Banner is supposed like this is the
physical body of the Hulk so if they
basically the the psyche of banner the
psyche of the Incredible Hulk basically
you know kind of operating inside this
body uh that Banner is actually
overtaken by the psyche of Betty Ross
the the kind of physical representation
we get here at least as far as we can
tell is basically Banner just kind of
being thrown out there it's not really
Banner being thrown into the physical
real world instead what it is is it's
actually Banner just being thrown out of
control right they're basically Betty
Ross is taking over that's kind of how
that works right so those of you guys
who are watching like Moon Knight right
now for example you know how like the
the Mind switch between like Steve Grant
and Mark Spector this is the equivalent
of win like Mark Spector takes over and
Steve Grant ends up going back there but
instead of Steve Grant like really
relinquishing control uh Mark Spector
just takes control that's basically how
this is working right now to give you
guys a better understanding of what's
going on because I know like on the
surface just looking at it it's like
wait a minute okay so like this Banner
physically exists no it's basically just
the Betty Ross Persona taking over the
body of the Incredible Hulk and forcing
the Bruce Banner Persona in into the
background right and so because of this
what you also end up learning here is
that this isn't actually Betty Ross it
looks like it's Betty Ross but it's not
actually Betty Ross right one of the
things she says is that where banners
begging right like you have to help me
here the the response she gives is like
look at you right helpless trapped at
the mercy of forces and violence out of
your control remind you of anybody and
and ultimately she says you never really
listen do you right I told you Bruce
Betty isn't real Betty's not here and
what she does is she ramps the engine up
and basically takes it to Stage six and
so now you have the Incredible Hulk
Persona facing off against demons
Mephisto dormammu right all these
different guys now here's Kind of a
Funny caveat to this right here's
something that you may not have noticed
one of the things that Donnie Cates is
doing is giving us a hierarchy of power
in Marvel Comics is very easy to miss
it's very easy to not notice but he's
giving us a hierarchy of power that in
essence you have stage one which is kind
of a relatively small threat but as the
stages go up the beings become more
powerful it wouldn't really make any
sense to ramp the incredible Hulk up to
Stage six and then like Here Comes The
Red Skull it wouldn't really make any
sense to do that and so Donnie Kate is
in effect giving us a hierarchy of power
in the Marvel Universe I can guarantee
you people are gonna reference this
right you go and you look at like battle
forms and different things like that or
you ask people you know in different
forms like who you know who's more
powerful you know like uh Odin or or
like dormammu right people are going to
be like well I mean according to Donnie
Cates and you know Hulk run it looks
like it's dormammu because dormammu was
a stage six villain or a stage six power
and Odin was stage five you know in that
kind of a thing right but it's a cool
little aside here it's a it's a smart
little thing and so in the end one of
the things that happens is that General
Thunderbolt Ross reveals to uh Bruce
Banner this alternate version of Bruce
that these bombs that he dropped are not
bombs in the traditional sense instead
what they are here are basically a means
of mutation that what's happening is
that inside each one of these canisters
are basically people that had become
that had been mutated even though
unintentionally by Banner but the ones
that Thunderball Ross had kept and that
these as as Thunderbolt Rossa first
refers to them are basically just like
Abominations right kind of like this
alternate reality version of abomination
here and so it's nuts because these
things are massive in size right they're
absolutely huge in size and so of course
this basically leads to Betty completely
taking over the body of the Incredible
Hulk completely pushing Banner's Persona
out of the way but in doing so she says
but I'm proud of you son and that's
where it seems to hit at this idea that
this is potentially Brian Banner now
this is where things get a little murky
because an alewings run one of the
things to remember in the immortal Hulk
is that it wasn't necessarily Brian
Banner it kind of was but it was
basically Brian Banner's Spirit or
Essence that had been overtaken by the
one below all and used to torment The
Incredible Hulk that's what that was it
wasn't actually Brian Banner himself and
so what this does is it builds on what
we've seen both in Al Ewing's runs a lot
of runs that came before it Bill mantlow
Peter David were basically the Brian
Banner Persona is kind of the uh the
controlling asp back now that's me
guessing here right just going on what's
sort of happening in terms of words that
Ryan Banner is the source of Bruce
Banner's torment and seemingly the most
powerful entity in his mind the one
thing that Banner just can't seem to
overcome but I could be entirely wrong
here this could very well be the the
mental Persona of the Titan Hulk right
like we don't know we won't know until
we get to the next issue but ultimately
that this Persona ends up ramping
everything up right like right past
stage seven and and right past stage
eight all the way to Stage Nine which is
basically just who really even knows
what this stage looks like presumably
it's the Titan Hulk but whatever it is
it literally leads to the Incredible
Hulk just absolutely losing it and
annihilating all these different
Abomination forces that are out there
and that's where it ends so presumably
this is where Titan Hulk comes into play
and if it does
I can't wait to see how this plays out
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Donnie Kate's astronaut
with the finale and we finally get the
Titan Hulk the most powerful version of
the Hulk that we've ever seen now for
those of you guys who want to get caught
up make sure you check the link in the
description or you can click on the card
here in the video which will take you to
the Hulk playlist that will get you
caught up on all this stuff but the long
and short of it is that the Incredible
Hulk is basically here in an alternate
reality and is facing off against these
altered versions of the Hulk basically
um these accidentally created versions
but the thing about this is that
remember Bruce Banner was the one
controlling the body of the Hulk and
that the Incredible Hulk Persona is in
the engine room basically serving as a
source of power because of its anger and
that somehow an alternate personality
which seems to be Brian Banner although
Donnie Cates hasn't necessarily
confirmed it has now seized control so
it's like if the Incredible Hulk body
was being controlled by an evil
personality is basically what it is now
the way in which uh Bruce Banner
basically amped Up The Incredible Hulk
or brought him down in terms of like how
much power he would need to face off
against a particular threat was
basically forcing The Incredible Hulk
personality to fight different levels of
villains that are out there so at the
Baseline level is like the Incredible
Hulk just walking along right and maybe
fighting fighting some guy or you know
fighting the Avengers or something like
that in the real world and so in the
engine room it would be these Baseline
villains really like nobody of any real
significance what we're seeing here is
what happens when that's amped up all
the way to Tim when basically it's the
most amount of power that could be taken
out of the Incredible Hulk right like
literally pushing him to his to his
highest level now Donnie Cates doesn't
necessarily confirm this but what he
says here or at least what this
indicates is if this is the most amount
of strength The Incredible Hulk can
possibly offer basically pushing him to
the Limit then it's Way Beyond anything
we've ever seen and the highest amount
of power that we've seen from The
Incredible Hulk up to this point was
heart of the monster when he was so
strong he was actually breaking the a
dark dimension the the dimension of
dormammu which at the time was ruled by
his sister Umar who literally showed up
in the main Marvel Universe asking
Doctor Strange for help because the
Incredible Hulk just couldn't be stopped
I mean it was crazy how powerful he was
still one of the best stories ever again
that's in the playlist as well if you
guys want to get caught up on that but
the thing about this is that with this
personality running the show it's really
just kind of offering this amazing meta
commentary coming in the form of Betty
Ross albeit seemingly actually being
somebody else what we're told here is
that it says everyone always says the
same thing that the Hulk is Bruce's
identity right his alter ego the
embodiment of a scared little boy
overwhelmed with impotent rage because
of the abuse he endured when he was a
little kid
right she just kind of shuffles it off
and that's true that's one of the best
things about this is this Donnie Cade's
kind of offering this meta commentary
now for those of you guys who don't know
what this means uh as we're going
through this I'll kind of give you guys
a little bit of a little bit of a
background here although you do get an
amazing moment where you basically have
like when it's amped up to level 10
which according to Bruce Banner is
basically theoretical he doesn't even
really know what would happen if that
were the case that basically it's the
Hulk versus the entire Marvel Universe
which in which includes the Living
Tribunal Thanos and a version of
Galactus who is the Hulk now there's a
reason behind that and I'll explain that
here in a second Because unless you're
familiar with Galactus you wouldn't know
why Galactus looks like the Incredible
Hulk and even this personality doesn't
know which is uh which is a really
really cool concept so the thing about
this is that when it comes to
uh The Incredible Hulk Mythos most
people out here whenever they go and
they buy an Incredible Hulk comic book
and they read an incredible whole comic
book what they want to see is the
Incredible Hulk just smashing that's
what they want to see
they want to see The Incredible Hulk
fighting really powerful people and
beating them up and just tearing things
up because that's what the Hulk is known
for now people who want a more like
character-centric run that was the old
bill mantlow and Peter David stuff Greg
pack focused on that to a degree but it
was more expanding The Incredible Hulk
Mythos and then focusing on like the
character of the Hulk insofar as it
related to like hirokawa and Scar the
sons he didn't know he had which were
really really cool and there were a few
other things that went in there but in
terms of like a character deconstruction
of the Hulk what's being referenced here
in terms of the fact that like the
Incredible Hulk personality is the
physical manifestation of just all the
rage that Bruce Banner experienced at
the hands of his father's abuse that's
all Bill mantlow and Peter David it was
initially we started by Bill Matt low
back in the day but he took off before
he could finish and then Peter David
continued it on and that's why one a lot
of people say the two go hand in hand
that when it comes to that era of the
Incredible Hulk is Bill mantlow and
Peter David together and two a lot of
people say that Peter David's run of the
Incredible Hulk is one of the most
important runs it's not the most
interesting run especially when you
compare it to something like Greg pact
which had a lot more action and a lot
more character development but in terms
of everything Greg pack did that was
built on the shoulders of Peter David So
Peter David's run is probably one of the
most significant runs if for no other
reason than the fact that it just sort
of changed the Hulk from like the old
Stanley Jack Kirby Days where he's just
like you know a monster running around
with the mind of a child and like
beating things up and like fighting
General Thunderbolt Ross and his army
and so on and so forth especially if you
look at the Roy Thomas era as well and
it changed him into like there's
actually more to the Incredible Hulk
than we initially thought now as far as
this whole scenario goes when it comes
to like why uh Galactus looks like the
Incredible Hulk I mean technically it is
the Incredible Hulk versus Galactus The
Living Tribunal and the Phoenix force it
is here in the engine room but the
reason why is something that was
established in a story called The Trial
of Reed Richards and we've talked about
this before but basically that set up
the idea that Galactus does not actually
have a physical form anymore he did back
when he was gallon before his Universe
before the Multiverse was destroyed and
then he re-emerged after merging with
that universe's version of Eternity
essentially when he was reborn into the
new universe as Galactus uh he had a
human form back when he was initially
just what you would call a human or a
sentient being but when he was reborn as
Galactus he's pure energy and so if you
saw him as he really is it would just be
a swirling mass of energy inside of a
giant purple suit and there's one point
where Odin like head butts Galactus and
shatters his helmet uh which I'm pretty
sure we did a video on that and that in
turn you actually see Galactus in what
looks like his human form but the
reality here is it's how an ass Guardian
would see him because in the trial of
Reed Richards what they set up and what
they stated is that Galactus is a mirror
for whatever race or whatever being sees
him so if you are a scroll and you see
Galactus he will look like a scroll if
you are a tree he'll look like a tree if
you're a human he'll look human and so
if you're an Asgardian he'll probably
look like an Asgardian which is why in
this instance the Incredible Hulk sees
Galactus and he sees an Incredible Hulk
so so the thing about this and what's
really cool is the Hulk literally amps
up and starts attacking everything
Wright starts attacking all of them now
the funny thing about this is during
this whole this whole situation the
entire monologue offered by this Betty
brand we can call it Betty Brant right
this Betty brand-esque person which is
most likely Brian Banner that literally
it says over the years there have been
so many hulks gray ones red ones blue
ones Wolverine ones which is actually
called weapon age and he was not that
interesting uh she says it seems to me
that well everyone gets to have a Hulk
these days Bruce has a Hulk Rick Jones
had a Hulk General Thunderbolt Ross had
a Hulk Jennifer Walters even had a hole
and she said Health even God has a Hulk
which is cool to see Donnie Cates
referencing the AL Yuen run where we
basically learned that the the one below
all is what happens when God hulks out
and so she's like it's really unfair
isn't it like why can't the Hulk have a
Hulk now this in this gives us two
things one is a retcon that everyone's
Glide happened and two is a new version
of The Hulk and so what we end up
getting like as this fight goes on
technically the Betty Ross Persona is in
the mind of the Incredible Hulk in the
real world the Incredible Hulk is
fighting in this alternate reality
against like all these different just
grotesque and mutilated versions of the
Hulk remember in this alternate universe
there was an effort to basically utilize
gamma energy as a source of renewable
energy things went wrong and instead of
becoming a renewable energy source it
ended up mutating a whole host of the
world's population into these different
versions of the Hulk and that's what the
Incredible Hulk's fighting now in the
real world so that's why I say assuming
to kind of keep in mind Donnie Cates
does it a little finicky right he does a
little a little weird but essentially
anytime you see somebody that looks like
they're in a cockpit they're in the mind
of the Incredible Hulk when you see the
version of the Incredible Hulk that
looks like a robot kind of that's
basically him in the real world so just
something to keep in mind here the thing
about this is that as this fight goes on
because the Hulk is being so readily
overpowered and quite literally being
slapped around what it ends up doing is
the Incredible Hulk himself hulks out
now this is something Marvel had done
before and it was ass so in the story of
axis basically the Incredible Hulk
hulked out into basically claw which was
the Incredible Hulk spelled backwards it
was a terrible idea uh ridiculously dumb
and so what we got instead of that was
this like Daddy cage just being like
this is what happens when the Hulk hulks
out uh he ends up becoming the Titan
Hulk which is nuts because he literally
looks part machine like it's just
ridiculously op which is absolutely
amazing I love this I mean dude the
guy's just spewing energy everywhere but
this is why I say this is what it looks
like this is seemingly the most powerful
version of The Incredible Hulk that
we've ever seen now there there are are
huge differences between this version of
The Hulk and like heart of the monster
and looking at these two you kind of
have to come from a feat's perspective
and in terms of like what each one is
capable of we saw what the heart of the
monster Hulk was able to do I mean again
shattering and like breaking apart the
dimension of one of the most powerful
magic wielders in existence which
depending on who's writing the story
dwarfs the power of doctor strange that
is crazy like literally them having to
take off from their Dimension and ask
doctor strange for help to deal with
that version of The Incredible Hulk so
we're not really seeing those same
levels of Feats now I would be curious
to see what happens if the Titan Hulk
ends up in the dark dimension again and
how that unfolds it would be pretty wild
and it would be pretty cool but this is
what happens when the Incredible Hulks
just strength rage anger all that kind
of stuff and really fear take hold and
is pushed to the absolute limit we just
get this massively grotesque huge thing
right and literally what what they're
saying is they're like I've never seen
anything like this before it's like 30
feet tall like the this thing is
enormous right I mean he's just huge
like it's just it's it's amazing
I absolutely love this so again here in
the real world in this alternate reality
you have General Thunderbolt Ross and
you have this alternate reality version
of Bruce Banner and this alternate
version of Bruce was in a lot of ways
kind of subservient to General
Thunderbolt Ross but only insofar as
this alternate reality version of Bruce
was basically a coward wrapped by guilt
and fear and so on and so forth and so
the reality here is Thunderbolt Ross
basically ends up getting on a getting
on the radio and calling in like a gamma
bomb detonation now the way this works
seemingly what would happen here is
somehow gamma radiation has been altered
by General Thunderbolt Ross to where
it's more akin to like a nuclear
explosion right enough that it would
just eradicate everything here and in
truth usually when it comes to like a
nuclear bomb or something like that it's
a combination of heat and force and
radiation right I mean if you're at
Ground Zero when a nuclear warhead goes
off or a nuclear bomb detonates which
technically it doesn't detonate on the
ground it detonates a little into the a
little above ground uh just to maximize
the area of Destruction I mean you would
be incinerated by the heat of
immediately and assuming you weren't
incinerated by the heat if you're close
enough to the blast I mean you'd
probably be knocked into a building and
just just killed that way right your
skull would be crushed by the impact but
assuming that doesn't happen the
radiation sickness would probably kill
you as well right I mean there's a lot
of ways to die as a result of a nuclear
bomb going off but like that really
seems to be what it is here right it
would just be like couldn't like
literally just heat and pressure it's
basically what general Thunderbolt Ross
is banking on whether or not it would
work we don't know I mean there are
literally been instances where like the
Incredible Hulk who's just kind of angry
has been able to withstand the power of
a nuclear bomb even Maestro right like
literally Maestro Hulk absorbed the
radiation that came from nuclear bombs
so we've seen different variations of
the Hulk over the years who could easily
withstand a nuclear explosion how a
gamma a weaponized gamma explosion would
impact the Hulk I don't entirely know I
mean literally the Hulk is living gamma
radiation my assumption would be that he
would just absorb it but the reality
here and the point that this alternate
version of Bruce Banner brings up is
that Thunderbolt Ross can't do that like
it's a terrible thing to do because if
he did thousands of people would die
because while we don't see them because
they're not the main focus here there's
basically a populated area right it's
not overly populated and they kind of
seem to be off out there and a little
bit of a distance but the the explosion
radius would be high enough or would be
wide enough that it would kill so many
innocent people and that in turn
Thunderbolt Ross just kind of like
overpowering or really just sort of
directing Bruce Banner is like no like I
don't care in the end like we'll both
end up killing thousands of people he
says because remember you're the reason
why these different versions of the Hulk
exist in the first place and you're the
one that brought this alternate Hulk
here so really this is all your fault
now the reality here is a thunderbolt
Ross to a degree trying to assuage his
guilty conscience if he even has one and
just trying to bring Bruce Banner down
with him but where this version of Bruce
is kind of a depiction of what would
happen if Bruce Banner just never grew
any balls he never became the Incredible
Hulk and was never like an enemy of
Thunderbolt Ross insofar as he was able
to overpower him likely humiliate him a
few times that the only thing you really
can do is muster up what courage he has
and he in turn attacks Thunderbolt Ross
and is like no I'm not going to let you
kill thousands of people now while you
know within the context of this
particular story it doesn't seem
significant or at least this particular
video over the course of the videos that
we've covered it's a huge moment because
this alternate reality version of Bruce
was constantly wrapped by guilt and
constantly felt like he was making
terrible mistakes and even then he
didn't realize that where he was
basically sending all these different uh
versions of the Hulk that they caught
across their world into The Ether right
into some into some portal somewhere
with no clue where they went to that
what was really going on is that he was
sending the ones out there that General
Thunderbolt Ross didn't want that what
Thunderbolt Ross was doing was going
around and grabbing those different
versions of the Hulk that he could use
that were that he thought were
weaponized so in reality he was at least
by his own imagination and kind of using
his own mind feeding into his own guilt
he was the reason why all these
different obamaized versions of the Hulk
were continued any way to live these
terrible existences under the servitude
of General Thunderbolt Ross because he
didn't know but had he not done what
he'd done in creating the gamma
detonation trying to create some kind of
renewable energy they never would have
been left to that fate in the first
place so the Screwed Up World in which
Bruce Banner lives here he largely takes
as being his fault him attacking
Thunderbolt Ross overpowering him
pointing that gun at him and saying no
like you're not going to kill anybody
anymore this is seemingly him overcoming
that guilt and accepting that not
everything bad that's going on now is
his fault right that like there are some
things out there that are just the
results of the fact that people are
dicks right like General Thunderball
Ross is just a terrible person who is
doing terrible things and despite what
Thunderbolt Ross said it was not the
fault of Bruce Banner now the other part
of this is that in the mindscape of the
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner kind of
claws his way back into to The
Incredible Hulk's mind more or less
where he was just kind of out there
basically it was a it was an in-comic
representation of the fact that like the
Bruce Banner Persona was forced to take
a back seat so ultimately of course with
him coming back in we do get this
version of Betty Ross's personality
which seemingly kind of alters and kind
of changes and takes on this different
form again we don't know exactly what
this is but I would go as far as to say
if the Titan Hulk is what happens when
the Hulk hooks out that this is the
mental representation of what the Titan
Hulk looks like we don't know that for
sure we're not 100 certain but in the
end there's this kind of discussion
where literally the personality is like
you have no power here Banner right like
you are weak you are pathetic you cannot
take control you cannot wrestle control
of the body away from me and the
response of of banner is I know but he
has the power to do it and in doing so
flips the switch like literally hits the
emergency switch and allows the
Incredible Hulk Persona to come in now
here's the thing it's amazing the way
this is drawn right like literally the
doors just half open and like the
Incredible Hulk Persona is just there
and it's like the head of Galactus is
behind him and he looks pissed and he
becomes smashing in here so what you're
seeing here right now is basically a
battle of personalities right it's the
Incredible Hulk personality versus the
Bruce Banner personality versus whatever
this new alternate personality is which
is seemingly the personality of the
Titan Hulk I would go as far as to say
that was the case but the way this is
drawn can get really really hairy and a
little bit confusing and so in essence
what happens here is that in the mind of
the Incredible Hulk right where you
basically have the Bruce Banner
personality the Titan Hulk personality
and the Incredible Hulk personality The
Incredible Hulk personality is able to
beat back the Titan Hulk personality in
the real world the Titan Hulk itself is
literally just unbridled energy that it
just can't control and so because it has
all this energy and because it doesn't
know how to control all this energy like
this is seemingly just a Mindless thing
it literally just Roars we never really
hear it speak or anything like that that
in the end all this energy just kind of
explodes in a massive explosion right it
just goes off right it literally just
blows up and so what you have here at
least momentarily is essentially a
reunification of personalities the Titan
Hulk personality has been beat back to
wherever it came from we don't really
know where it came from but presumably
it just resides down there in the
mindscape somewhere and that as a result
of the destruction of the quote unquote
real world Titan Hulk uh now it's
basically just the Incredible Hulk back
in its normal form and so at this point
Banner basically runs back into the
cockpit right the mind of the Incredible
Hulk and in doing so re-season's control
and as that goes on of course this gamma
bomb is falling and it is gonna it's
gonna cost so much life and so what ends
up happening is there's a conversation
between alternate reality banner and the
Incredible Hulk band right Banner one
Banner two Banner three but you end up
having like this this conversation
between these where alternate reality
Banner is like look this gamma bomb is
falling you have to do something right
like I have an idea and so you know
Prime Banner we can call him that Banner
from the main Marvel universe is like
then what do you want me to do and
Alternate Banner is like I'm opening a
portal and basically that bomb is going
to come through that portal and it's
gonna land here right it's gonna end up
here where I am but in the end it's the
rightful thing to do I've caused nothing
but just death and destruction and just
horrible things uh I wouldn't go I mean
he doesn't go as far as to say like it's
the faith that awaits me but he says
like I really hope that you don't end up
like me I really hope that you don't end
up in this place where you're basically
like this kind of horrible terrible
villain what you have here in the form
of the Incredible Hulk is quite
literally a gift use it right like use
it as a gift treat it with respect but
use it to do good things now this is
actually a really really cool concept
because what this does is it gives us
perspective that the only real
perspective we have when it comes to the
Incredible Hulk is what we've seen over
the course of Marvel Comics and
potentially some alternate realities and
unless you're looking at like Warren
Ellis's Marvel the end you don't really
see a whole lot of like totally screwed
up twisted up versions of the Incredible
Hulk but that's all this alternate
reality Banner knows I'll just twist
screwed up versions of the Hulk and so
as a result of this once that bomb goes
through and of course it ends up
detonating that the portal is reopened
and banner or at least the Incredible
Hulk anyway travels through it to
wherever his destination ends up taking
him next he has no clue where it is that
he's going to end up going all he knows
is that literally at the moment the
hammer of all father Thor which was
recently reassembled by Angela and the
angels of heaven is making its way
towards the Hulk so in essence what
we're apparently going to see here which
makes perfect sense because literally
it's the 60th anniversary of the
Incredible Hulk and Thor fighting for
the first time that what we're going to
end up getting is all father Thor
against probably the Titan Hulk which I
am ridiculously excited to see
so Titan Hulk fights an army of 500
World breaker hulks in this video and
it's amazing check this out so what this
does is this initially picks up with
Bruce Banner in control of Starship Hulk
now people who have no idea what's going
on in The Incredible Hulk Mythos right
now are probably like what
explain this to me man so here's what's
happening right now in years past you
had the Incredible Hulk who turned into
Bruce Banner and Bruce Banner who turned
into the Incredible Hulk the angrier The
Incredible Hulk got the stronger he
became what's been going on recently and
we didn't know how Bruce Banner did it
but we are going to find out in this
video what Bruce Banner managed to do
was basically take control of the
Incredible Hulk's body and then have the
Incredible Hulk Persona operate as a
kind of engine for his own body so
literally what Bruce Banner does is he
just bombards the Incredible Hulk
personality with an endless onslaught of
increasingly powerful characters it
starts off with somebody like Wolverine
and goes all the way up to people like
Thanos they're all just psychic
projections but the Hulk personality
doesn't know that so it just continues
to fight over and over and over and over
again and because the Incredible Hulk
gets stronger the angrier he gets by
increasing the difficulty of the
villains that the Hulk personality has
to fight that's how Banner controls how
strong The Incredible Hulk gets to be or
at least the body gets to be it's pretty
cool but of course with him in control
of Starship Hulk he basically crash
lands on a world that he's not familiar
with because at this point in time the
Incredible Hulk or really Banner is
traversing the Multiverse he's literally
exploring the whole Multiverse what
makes sense of all that is we go through
this video but in arriving on this world
he doesn't recognize anything here the
only thing he sees that even just seems
remotely recognizable is just this giant
Citadel that's been built and seemingly
it's been built in his honor because
there's just a giant statue of The
Incredible Hulk now of course he's
almost immediately set upon by just
these crazy monstrous looking Hulk type
things that are called the gray but then
he's almost immediately rescued by a
chick named monolith now we'll learn
more about her because she's incredibly
important here but what she does is she
explains what what's going on in this
alternate reality that Bruce Banner's in
and what she says is that at some point
along the line a just whole bunch of
Hulks suddenly arrived on this world
they literally fell through a portal and
arrived on this world and that they did
what hulks do they just started smashing
things they were smashing the world to
such a degree that they terraformed it
they terraformed a planet through
smashing it and that's going to be one
of the craziest things because every
single one of these hulks are all World
breaker level but of course as they're
smashing and basically terraforming this
world as time progresses the exceedingly
violent nature of these original hulks
begins to go away and what they end up
doing is forming a more organized and
structured Society now the other part of
this seems to be that with the loss of
their violent nature their gamma
radiation almost seems to kind of
dissipate in the sense that they do have
enough gamma to basically maintain their
forms some level of their strength but
by and large they're just kind of really
strong guys and that's it but then like
out of nowhere the sun seemingly
explodes and there's just like this
giant Vestige of the original Hulk right
the main Hulk and he just starts
blasting them like covering them all
with gamma radiation now that's how
monolith describes it what's actually
really going on here is it looks like
the arrival of this original Hulk kind
of reawakens all the gamma radiation
inside their bodies and turns them back
into their exceedingly strong cells
basically sends them back into their
world breaker forms and so looking at
the original Hulk or the main Hulk as
kind of the person that returned them to
Glory they built the whole statue and
everything and so while monolith doesn't
really know the significance of where
all the original hulks came from by
passing through a portal or seeing a
Vestige of the main Hulk in the sky we
do know all that stuff and this was all
based on the previous story arc which
you'll find a link to in the comments
section make sure you guys check for a
pinned comment that'll take you to that
video but the way the previous storyline
played out is that when Bruce Banner
first entered into the Multiverse he
encountered an alternate reality version
of himself and that alternate Bruce
under the direction of that universe's
version of Thunderbolt Ross was
basically trying to create an army of
Hulk those who were considered to be
failures or cast-offs were literally
just sent through a wormhole and no one
knew where they went to they were just
out of sight out of mind and that was
basically it now everything popped off
and we saw the Titan Hulk for the first
time which we'll talk about in this
video and so on and so forth but that's
where they originally came from what is
important here is that monolith brings
Hulk basically to all the other hulks in
this city and kind of presents him as
sort of the original right like the one
they all Champion as the person that
gave them all their gamma radiation
right like the Hulk above all hulks if
you want to call them that right the
prime Hulk and so they see him very much
as kind of a champion of the people more
so than that what they also do is they
bring him into something called the god
ball games now this is just an
indication of how strong these different
hulks are right this planet has three
rings of rocks around it in the same way
that Saturn has rings right so what
these hulks do is they jump to a
neighboring world and they smash the
world right they literally just beat it
and they hammer it all the way down to
the point that it's as close as far as
the atomic structure of everything that
it can possibly get right there's no way
to compact this core any further and
when they have that they call it a god
ball they bring the god ball back to
Hulk Planet which is what this place is
called then they use it as a game they
throw it at the rocks and whoever
destroys the most rocks wins the idea of
breaking a world is now just a game of
sport breaking worlds is just what they
do for fun and it's just nuts right it's
just a whole different level of strength
and so of course basically the
Incredible Hulk participates in the
whole thing he's just like sure why not
grab the giant core of a planet that's
been condensed down to virtually nothing
and start throwing it into things for
sport and for fun why not be a part of
this now seemingly the god ball games
are just interrupted out of nowhere by a
group that's referred to as the
alternative Universe timeline Hazard
operations response and intervention
team which if you've put those acronyms
together correctly spells Authority now
is it the authority from DC Comics No
but it's absolutely a Pastiche on the
team it's basically just Donnie Cates
and Marvel Comics making fun of the
authority they're over the top they
present themselves with this Grand level
of authority that none of them have and
of course they're basically going after
the Hulk because the whole kid basically
destroyed the previous version of
authority as he was flying through the
Multiverse now of course at this point
monolith chimes in and says well
actually what was happening is the Hulk
was sleeping didn't really know what he
was doing your guys just got in his way
and with the horde being as strong as he
is he plowed through your entire team so
that's really the only reason why this
happened now of course the other thing
that ended up happening is that the Hulk
himself along with a guy named pave
who's another one of the hulks here is
actually just transported to a different
world which they proceed to smash and
create another God ball out of but the
authority is being here is really more
just kind of a goofy moment it's just a
silly moment I just thought it'd be a
funny thing to reference otherwise we
would have normally just skipped over it
but of course with like the Hulk himself
returning alongside pave as well as
having the god ball they continue on
with the grand games themselves
completely and blissfully unaware of the
fact that the Hulk personality inside
the Incredible Hulk body is starting to
become disillusioned and the Titan Hulk
is starting to manifest again now here
is where things get a little murky when
it comes to the nature of the Titan Hulk
when the Titan Hulk first manifested in
Marvel Comics it manifested as a
personality Inside the Mind Of The
Incredible Hulk itself meaning you had
Bruce Banner's personality you had the
Hulk's personality then you had another
that showed up in the form of Betty Ross
now we knew right off the bat it was not
Betty Ross and even within the story
Bruce Banner knew it wasn't Betty Ross
but we didn't really know what it was
what ends up happening is that over the
course of this story that personality
starts to appear as Brian Banner the
abusive father of Bruce Banner but do
not be fooled by the appearance that the
Titan Hulk takes that when it does
appear to the whole personality it shows
up as almost kind of like a shadow King
type entity right very malevolent it's
difficult to make out its exact form
it's very dark very scary very murky
that kind of a thing spouting stuff like
your soul belongs to me your mind
belongs to me it's only a matter of time
before I take over yada yada all the
kind of stuff you expect to see and even
when the whole personality goes to
attack the Titan Hulk Persona the Titan
whole Persona just shuts it down right I
mean just easily overtakes that version
of the Hulk like that I mean it's not
even a contest and in fact we'll see
just how powerful this guy is because
it's next level but one of the things to
know is that with the Titan Hulk
personality basically amping up and
beginning to seize control we've only
ever seen glimpses of how powerful the
Titan Hulk is and this video we'll find
out just what this dude is capable of
now the other part of this is that once
the Titan whole Persona does take hold
Stephen Strange actually picks up on it
now here's the thing about this yes
within Marvel Comics those of you guys
who are reading Stephen Strange is
technically dead this story takes place
after the death and return of Stephen
Strange why because it's comic books and
nothing stays changed forever and so
with Titan Hulk taking control of every
we think Doctor Strange actually ends up
getting involved but the reason he gets
involved is not for the reason that you
think and so what this does is this
leads to the Titan Hulk actually
initiating a series of enemies against
the Hulk personality under the belief
that in doing so the whole personality
will just face off against this endless
horde of enemies grow more and more
powerful and then when that time comes
basically amp himself up and allow the
Titan Hulk to take over right allow the
Titan Hulk to seize control and then
manifest in a physical form the problem
with this is that Bruce Banner and the
Hulk personality are actually meditating
together which is something that they've
done over the course of Donnie Kate's
run so far they literally sit down
meditate and they don't allow anything
to bother them and so for the most part
all these threats that literally keep
being thrown against the Hulk none of
them seem to have any bearing whatsoever
even when you have like a manifestation
of the Phoenix Thanos Galactus none of
it seems to really impact the Hulk on a
meaningful level but at the end of the
day the Titan Hulk pushes things to the
absolute limit and literally amps up the
Incredible Hulk the max level the
highest level he possibly can and just
explodes and that's the nature of the
Titan Hulk the Titan Hulk is the answer
to the question when Bruce spanner gets
pushed to his limits he becomes the
Incredible Hulk what happens when the
Hulk hulks out you get the Titan Hulk
it's a pretty awesome concept because
when that happens the Titan Hulk is now
in full control now jumping to Doctor
Strange this is the reason why he's
getting involved in the first place so
while we didn't initially know how it
was that Banner was able to take over
the mind of the Hulk and then Force the
whole personality to basically become
the engine system where we didn't know
how he was able to turn the Incredible
Hulk body into basically a vessel that
could Traverse the Multiverse without
being destroyed by the pressures of just
space time and all that kind of stuff we
end up finding out that Bruce Banner had
previously met with Doctor Strange and
Doctor Strange had actually showed him
how to do that but he had shown him how
to take over the body or at least the
mind of the Hulk how to seize control
for himself and then after learning how
to do that that what Banner had done is
he had actually taken over one of
modoc's tech facilities and then started
imbuing himself with a technology
necessary to be able to Traverse the
space waste right to travel the
Multiverse so that's how all this
seemingly came to where it is right now
now of course when Stephen Strange
realizes what's going on he ends up
sending its astral form into the
Multiverse in order to find uh Bruce
Banner on Hulk Planet and then find a
way to bring the entire conflict to an
end because he kind of sees himself as
being responsible for all of this but
here's the crazy thing about it with
Titan Hulk manifesting and with all
these different world breaker hulks here
on this world they didn't know what they
were getting into right they weren't
necessarily goading the existence of the
Titan Hulk and if anything what they
were actually trying to do was get rid
of the Bruce Banner personality it was
one of the main goals of monolith and
like pave and any of them they saw the
Hulk as the true personality of banner
and the banner personality had to be
eliminated and so by working to get rid
of like all the implants in the Hulk
body getting rid of the technological
advancements and so on and just turning
him into a more pure version of the Hulk
while I wouldn't go as far as to say
they're the reason why Titan manifested
in the first place I would go so far as
to say they have no idea what they're
dealing with here because as soon as
Titan Hulk shows up monolith sends
Oliver forces after Titan and when she
does they all get wrecked not even hell
would you see a master like this to say
they get wrecked is just an
understatement right I don't know what
word can adequately be used to
illustrate what's going on here but
these guys never stood a chance in the
first place any attack they launch
against Titan Hawk is met with virtually
no impact whatsoever he doesn't even
really feel anything while Doctor
Strange astral form does show up it does
basically step into the mind of Bruce
Banner and try to fight the personality
of the Titan Hulk while the world
breaker hulks try to fight the physical
form of the Titan Hulk none of it's
helping none of it makes any difference
whatsoever literally the Stephen Strange
Persona is blown out of the mind of
Titan Hulk and then in turn the Titan
Hulk turns his attention to these 500
World breaker Hooks and just starts
sucking all the gamma radiation right
out of them amping himself up even more
and making himself more and more
powerful so much so that what monolith
does is she tells all the other world
breaker hulks that are left to get out
of there while they can right evacuate
leave lest they die and so that's when
Stephen Strange realizes what's actually
going on here what he does is he jumps
back to his Citadel he grabs an orb and
then brings it back to this alternate
universe with his astral form and then
he presents the orb and the person who
emerges from it is despair now despair
is a ridiculously powerful entity in
Marvel Comics and is one of the most
powerful fear Lords to ever exist in the
history of Marvel I mean this guy's
right up there with beings like
nightmare the dweller in darkness so on
and so forth what we end up finding out
here is that for reasons that are never
truly revealed when Bruce Banner met
with Stephen Strange to learn how to
control the mindscape it was never
Stephen Strange that he actually met
with it was despair masquerading as
Stephen Strange which is a crazy
revelation because again despair only
answers to some of the most powerful
beings in existence which seems to
indicate there are forces out there
within the Multiverse that are of
exceedingly high levels of power that
have a vested interest in seeing the
Titan Hulk personality run a complete
and total Rampage across the Multiverse
which basically seems to happen because
when the attempts by Despair and Stephen
Strange are implemented to contain and
control the Titan Hulk it's too late and
Titan Hulk is seizing control of
everything he's gonna eradicate the
world he's going to destroy every world
in the vicinity in this immediate solar
system spread to the Galaxy the universe
and even the Multiverse and there's
seemingly nothing anybody can do to stop
it
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are getting the conclusion of Titan Hulk
along with the origin of his character
which is really really cool so what this
does here is this initially picks up in
the mind of Bruce Banner with a little
bit of taunting from despair right
remember because of the fact of the
Titan Hulk basically originates in the
mind of banner when Doctor Strange got
involved his physical form is on his way
to Planet Hulk his spiritual form is in
the mind of banner right so he's just
there trying to get rid of the Titan
Hulk the best he can the problem is he
ends up encountering the fear Lord
despair but the thing about despair is
he's ridiculously op and in recent years
he was easily defeated by Doctor Strange
in a way that normally shouldn't have
been done but what despair does is he
actually gives us this kind of origin of
the Titan Hulk and telling us that what
had happened is that somewhere along the
line a green door manifested to despair
now anybody who's familiar with the Hulk
Mythos knows the significance of the
green door but that really comes from Al
Ewing's run so for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar familiar with
that and again I'll have a link to the
Hulk playlist from Al Ewing down in the
comments section but when it came to the
Green Door the way this worked is that
in years past you just had people who
became different versions of the Hulk
Jennifer Walters became Incredible Hulk
doc Samson became dot green Bruce Banner
became the Incredible Hulk and so on and
so forth but what Al Ewing did is he
introduced the idea of the Green Door
that in effect whenever a person with
gamma radiation in their body and they
are a Hulk whenever they die a green
door opens and they can be reborn they
can basically come back to life it's a
roundabout way for immortality now we
ended up learning that the origin of the
Green Door actually came from the one
below all who was basically an answer to
the question what happens when the one
above all hulks out it was a pretty
insane Revelation at the end of that
story right like the god of the Marvel
Multiverse has a Hulk form and it's the
one below all it was pretty dope but
what despair says is that it was
presented with a kind of power or at
least a little semblance of Power by
this being now what despair says is that
this little nugget it was given that
comes in the form of a red ball that it
was only a small form or a small
fraction of this being's power that it
had an astronomical amount of power now
by all standards of measurement it was
the one below all that gave this power
to Despair and anybody who knows
anything about our coverage valuings
Hulk will tell you guys the one below
all is immensely powerful I mean there
was literally a point in the story where
alguing showed us what would happen in
the future when the one below all seized
control of the Hulk that it basically
destroys the whole Multiverse it's
reborn into the new Multiverse after
killing Franklin Richards and Galactus
and then destroys the next Multiverse
then it would just wipe these things out
continually until the end of time it was
a really awesome Revelation but because
of the power of the one below all even
just a fraction of it that despair was
overwhelmed by it right just like God
this is insane and in fact what was
instructed of Despair is that he was to
take this little fraction of what seems
to be the one below all's power and
place it inside the mind of banner and
that's where the Titan comes from it's
an external power source that is slowly
manifested and kind of gains sentience
over the years and that's why we were
never really given a definitive
explanation of where the Titan Hulk came
from it's not some alternate personality
of Bruce Banner it's not some long-lost
aspect of his anger and rage that he
never quite dealt with it's a foreign
body right it's like having some kind of
illness in his body a kind of cancer
that's just been growing over time and
manifests in the form of the Titan Hulk
now what this does here is it basically
leads to again this Revelation that
Stephen Strange's physical form is on
its way but with his spiritual form
basically overtaken by the combined
power of Despair as well as the Titan
Hulk Persona that what this does is it
actually leads to the body and the mind
of Stephen Strange merging their power
is completely reunified and then in turn
they're able to cast off the power of
Despair and effectively lock him away so
the only thing the only major issue that
we have left here is the Titan Hulk
itself right this physical manifestation
in the real world and this guy is laying
waste to every thing right like even
Steven strange isn't fully sure what to
do because the level of power that the
Titan Hulk possesses here is
astronomical and if it really is a Hulk
powered by the one below all then there
really isn't anything that can be done
here but as this whole conflict is going
on monolith is doing her best to hold
off the power of the Titan Hulk but for
monolith's part one of the revelations
that comes out here is that in her fight
against Titan Hulk that where it
initially looked like she was beating on
him as best she could she was just kind
of doing what hulks do which is
physically attacking him blasting him
with her staff and magical energy and so
on what she's actually been doing this
whole time was siphoning off his power
was siphoning the power away from Titan
Hulk and it diminishes his capabilities
he's not nearly as capable as he was but
this is where the miscalculation of
monolith comes into play does she quite
literally siphons his power off and then
blasts him with it in the hopes it'll
destroy him and it sends him flying of
course not when that happens the other
hulks who were here who Titan Hulk just
absolutely demolished with the greatest
of ease that what happens is they
approach sure and they basically tell
her like you've saved us everything's
okay and her response is no I haven't I
haven't saved anything like it was my
miscalculation I absorbed his energy and
I blasted him with his own energy hoping
it would destroy him and it didn't he's
absorbing it all right he's back to 100
again and he even has whatever energy I
had residually in my staff he's more
powerful than he was before and so
literally her response is we're
basically doomed there's no way our
world can be saved and even Steven
strange himself says that right he's
like with this level of power that
you're dealing with here there's no way
to save your world it's going to fall
and it's going to be destroyed and even
despair tells Stephen Strange that's the
goal here right the goal of Titan Hulk
is to siphon all the gamma radiation off
of this world in any other world that
exists in this universe and then destroy
the universe and move on to the next one
right so in a lot of ways what it looks
like Donnie case is doing is kind of
building off of what Al Ewing did sort
of giving us this depiction of the
events that took place between the time
when the one below all sees control of
the Incredible Hulk and that futuristic
story where the one above all have been
traveling throughout the Multiverse and
just wiping out whole universes over and
over and over again it's not explicitly
told to us that's what this is but it
would be a cool place to kind of fit it
into so it's awesome it's a really
really cool depiction on this thing but
again one of the things to understand
and just demonstrating the sheer level
of power that Titan Hulk has not even
Steven strange can stop this guy now you
can make transitive property arguments
right we can cook the books in power
scaling and say well you know you know
maybe he's more powerful than dormammu
or something like that I don't
definitively know but what I will tell
you is a being as capable as Titan Hulk
seemingly imbued with the power of the
one below all is enough to go against
virtually anybody out there and it
doesn't matter who they are so no wonder
Steven strange can't beat this guy and
so what ends up happening here its
Banner starts talking to the Incredible
Hulk in his own mind because remember
the physical form of Hulk Banner
whatever you want to call it that's
Titan Hulk running around but Inside the
Mind banner and Hulk are kind of trapped
there and so what Banner starts doing is
talking to the Hulk and saying you have
to do something we have to manifest
something has to happen here like if we
do nothing this entire world and all the
hulks on it will be completely
eradicated we'll be stuck here because
Steven strange will inevitably die and
then this Titan Hulk will literally
travel to our Homeworld wipe out
everybody there and we'll be helpless to
do anything but just sit there and watch
it happen so if you care about nothing
Hulk then continue doing nothing but if
the lives of the people here matter and
if the lives of everybody at home
matters then do something step up and do
something and it's one of the coolest
things right because while that's going
on Titan Hulk is dominating everybody
right like Stephen Strange opens up a
portal to try to get the occupants of
this this whole planet to like a
different world Titan Hulk like
basically rips a hole through that
reality like tears a hole in reality and
then jumps through I mean it's crazy the
only time we've ever really seen a being
based on physical power do anything like
this was during the try on Juggernaut
story if you guys remember that when
trial Juggernaut was punching holes in
reality it was nuts right we covered
that and in fact we'll remaster it
because it's just a ridiculously amazing
story but it was just this op version of
Juggernaut punching holes in the
universe it was nuts it's not something
that we see very often and so what ends
up happening is that because of the
pleading of banner The Incredible Hulk
finally steps up now the irony of this
is that when the Hulk does step up the
Titan Hulk Persona basically tells him
there's nothing I need from you anymore
right like I've siphoned off everything
I need I've got your physical body
nothing here matters but something to
understand here is that the entire basis
the entire foundation of the Titan
Hulk's existence is predicated on the
Hulk itself if the Hulk isn't there the
Titan Hulk's power basically wanes
because there's nothing for that Persona
to latch onto there's nothing for it to
become a part of right like it's a
really interesting Prospect because what
this does is it actually leads to both
banner and Hulk working together and
then punching a hole through Titan Hulk
and then leaving the physical body right
like actually exiting out of the
physical body when that happens Hulk
reverts back into Banner's form and then
in turn the entire conflict ends right
you literally switch over to Banner in
strange Academy now here's the thing and
this is something that caught me off
guard right because it just suddenly
ends and it's just like what like it's
just it's suddenly over the reason why
the story ends this way is because
Donnie Cates the guy who's writing this
is basically taking a mental health
break he's walking away from the
Incredible Hulk series so it just ends
suddenly like without any wheel any any
real thing the only thing we're given
here is some measure of an epilogue
where basically doc Samson writes a
letter to Bruce Banner telling him like
none of us blame you for anything that's
happened none of this is your fault or
anything like that right like you should
come back to Planet Hulk sometime or
Hulk Planet or whatever and hang out
right it'd be really cool if we all hung
out and did God ball and all that kind
of stuff right as far as Titan Hulk's
concerned its power is basically
non-existent right like it's just not
really there anymore the force of power
that was being used to create it has
effectively left and of course we end up
finding out that source of power ends up
transitioning back to the person that
originally gave it who's basically the
leader who's imbued with the power of
the one below all from Al Ewing's run
right the leader of course being a
former Incredible Hulk villain but like
it just ends all of a sudden right it's
just like and we're done and that's
basically it because Donnie case his
entire run was cut short because he was
focusing on a mental health break so a
very lackluster ending to what was
otherwise a phenomenal Incredible Hulk
story but thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace